salut à tous ces pêcheurs de 13h alors
aujourd'hui on est au bord d'un canal
donc pour une partie de pêche aliments
c'est très prometteur on n'est pas loin
d'une grande ville il ya des gens qui
promènent leur chien ouais donc on va
tâcher rasta pourquoi qui nous embête et
c'est parti pour la pêche aliments
il ya beaucoup de vases sûrement de
plastique c'est bien parce qu on attrape
les grâces aux ferrailles etc et offrant
un bon coin de pêche pêche
c'est des morceaux que tu as dis tout ça
[Musique]
asensi génie
c'est de voir ce qu'il ya dans le born
que de la vase et des déchets se
déclassent
regarde moi ça ça fait une très belle
dépollution
[Musique]
un jeune chef de pêcheurs
un cadre de vélo ou décathlon et pas
vieux bravo battre oreilles bref
français on va en faire des choses au
noir
car
elle est pleine ah dommage
ah ouais
aie aie aie
armes de meurtre
non ou des couche-tôt lui aussi à la été
aiguisés à la main soit les marques
non l3
une épuisette
ouais
bravo
bay nickel
ça peut servir encore
le boire un coup beauty qui lipton
un
os non core impôts
ça c'est encore un pot avec un message
mais celui-là il n'y a pas de l'o2 à
londres et comme du miel
ça c'est pas de l'eau dedans c'est
encore la sorcellerie se rassurent tik
tok on me devais de la sorcellerie avec
du cumin noir ouais est-ce que vous avez
une idée de ce que ça pourrait de cette
couleur andrée du miel on nous avait
aussi dit de faire gaffe et de ne pas
les ouvrir un barbu ou cinq ans il ya un
message aussi envoyer un message
peut-être cette fois on pourra le lire
et ce qui est fou c'est que c'est
exactement le même pot
déjà à 6 facile
d'imaginer un doigt ou un truc infâme
comme crème de soin
crois que c'est vraiment kepler n'est
plus du sport tas ça va être dur on a
d'ailleurs été un message de l'endroit
ah oui à des graines ou quoi je pense
écriture
on apprend peu le sortilège
sauber
une chaise de pêcheurs
elle est si lourde
alors pas de pêcheurs à
6,7 pêcheurs mais ouais pas
au bal en bon état
bravo belle trouvaille
ouais ouais
ouais ouais comme un serpent revend aux
ferrailleurs
reagan oui oui oui oui oui oui oui
[Musique]
oui ac oui tu apprends des choses à et
celle ci aurait
ouais
[Musique]
bah oui c'est ça réaliser ses rêves
d'enfant
merci bonne balade
aujourd'hui les amis on s'éloigne un peu
de pêcheurs de trésors je pense qu'on va
être plus sûr du nettoyage qu il y aura
quelques trouvailles mais ouais
franchement c'est très sale ici regardez
approcher
ici vous avez le grand classique
de ski doit y avoir pas milliers ouais
canal mais voilà bon nettoyage et
surtout il ya des dizaines et des
dizaines de sacs plastiques ouais en
tout genre ça c'était mal a qui sont
plus enroulés dans des fils de pêcheur
ouais et ça c'est je pense qu'il y en a
du canal remplace chez nous la seule
solution pour quoi ils attrapent c'est
qu'il ya un bout de fer entre les mains
et ce plastique là et rien que dans ce
cas là bas ça arrive en fait presque à
chaque lancer donc plutôt plutôt
dégueulasse on va faire c'est qu'on va
continuer nettoyant va se décaler un peu
vers la gauche pour s'éloigner un peu
plus de la ville et voir si c'est aussi
ça la
pâte dans l'eau
à essayer quelque chose qui vient pas
à ça y est j'ai
au un poste de radio
ils étaient bien en basé sur la
radio k7
way
inventé donc ça c'est les solides en
plus
qu'ils avaient du mal le m belle
trouvaille
à trop se fait avec un badge de
résidence
sympa
aux îles xisha
à la déception
non
alors que la partie haute à l'arrêt
tumeur de la merde moi j'ai peur d'une
chicha entière je suis trop d bah oui je
me suis pas blessé je suis trop deg j'ai
autre chose à
chier
[Musique]
enfin
bravo
super well est sympa à la chaîne et
quand même déjà bien rouillée ouais
c'est quoi ce tu commençais 3 pasqua
sénateur
+ 1 me
tracasser les rayons attention
voilà
au
itunes
c'est parce que c'est comme ça voilà ça
va errer dehors ça ira mieux j'ai
quelque chose où c'est lourd au sein
peau et ce serait pas pour catalyseurs
en brèche et pas
ouais ça vaut cher je crois
[Musique]
c'est possible que ce soit ouais mais
dans ce cas là il aurait volé il se
serait fait surprendre ou alors il y en
avait pas dans celui-là
60 rampe et n'avait pas la
prendre en main ces mais c'est cru y à
rien on regarde on voit à travers des
bas ou alors ils ont des vidéos ou alors
c'est justement pas cette partie là
c'est sur une autre vous ouais ouais
ratha expertise
typiquement et pas faire tomber un
portable les américains ils font des
iphone ils en font 10 sur une journée
j'avais fait un
une pince saas et les pêcheurs
à sympa
c'est une pince multi toul
en très bon état
voir parfaite et à la baisse est la même
que j'avais déjà fait mais qui était
cassé super un rasta et belles
trouvailles oh
regarde j'ai du pâté
les cas c'est d'un côté qui sort pas
manquer les casser sa porte pas malheur
c'est quoi ça c'est dégueulasse il
regarde
ouais
tu veux pas tu es un star
celui qui mange ça les gars
non et ça c'est pas encore vraiment
sotchi chats n'ont peut-être pas ça la
moindre saute vite
bizarre bizarre il ya des choses
étranges dans ce canal quand même un
du poste encore
non 5 offre une caisse caisse
enregistreuse caisse de heynckes avait
nommé une caisse de magasins temps il
restait des pièces aux donc c'est pas
évident ouais probablement cambrioler
qu'est ce que c'est il ya un élastique
autour
de qui étonnant on va regarder si vous
avez une idée un commentaire ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on a
pu croire ouais cassé clasico il ya des
choses un chéquier ouais façon à y est
vide et fermée ok
la
haye à un motif dessus
une mère qui embrasse son enfant je
crois on voit pas trop
ça soit la
haye
mais la phase inexactes ou une
poinçonneuse bref un prophète et ouais
sympa ensuite
où là il ya un papier dedans non
pas nettoyés à l'eau claire ce que l'on
voit pas ouais vous y pose notre côté
pour revenir à le nettoyer
ensuite à batz et les agrafes d aggraver
des recherches ouais
le salat fait rien encore des papiers
engrais dateront autant
penguins mais toi ton papier pour
nettoyer aussi je crois qu'il est mort
ouais en rien à un autre
voilà où il ya encore des choses une
carte une carte super peut-être pour
identifier la personne oui il ya un nom
un kart de médecins le médecin peut-être
que sinon l'un d'eux est un homme très
c'est une carte de médecins expire fin
2006 la wii jurés ça explique l'état de
la boîte carte de professionnel de santé
bien il ya un paquet avait quelque chose
à l'intérieur au louvre une fois rentré
au super pêche déjà bah ouais là c'est
bien là c'est vraiment les endroits où
tu as tous les grands classiques fresque
sas a remplacé coffres forts ces petites
caisses et c'est vrai que quand trop
fort c'est quand même pas jeter en
pleine ville
un antivol
hn2 je pense pas mais c'est bien à
chaque fois les ventes
c'est fou quoi
ils le font mal ah si l'état sur un truc
ouais ça c'est la tâche à un poteau oui
oui oui
pour moi c'est ça
parce que c'est 90% des antivols qu'on a
trouvés ils s'étaient pas casser
voyager trop à droite c'est de la merde
ah pardon
par mois
ouais ils se nourrissent que de bière et
de boîtes de conserve ici j'ai quelque
chose en plein milieu
voyons voir
abaisser encore une boîte non
pas dommage est plus récente
dommage dommage
bah je retire j'ai retiré il ya des
pièces non à une pièce là il y en a
d'autres à main sa vie mais je vais
retirer là bas tu vois tu rentres séjour
âge et ouais bah y'a pas que les
ceintures rouges ah dommage cela aurait
pas
radôme injures
[Musique]
pas de chance quand on trouve deux
boîtes au même endroit c'est à dire que
c'est peut-être d'autres comme new york
enfin le décompte des centimes trouver
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut arriver
au moins à 50 centimes
ce qui est une très belle journée pour
de la pêche annuel
vraiment petit resto
sens pas vieille celle là même le bleu
là il est encore bien éclatant
une pointe ni
une poignée de porte ok
bon je pense qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
pia saint jean n'est même pas fait en
tirant trois au même endroit alors c'est
le téléphone il a pris l'eau ça on
dirait encore une fois le jeu là où tu
allais les anneaux il est pas si vieux
franchement ce n'est pas trop bloqué à
bien jouer
il a une carte sim cartes sim orange
quartiers et pas de carte mémoire par
contre sont ces modèles il me semble je
crois mais les rangs plutôt bon état
et prépayés on n'a pas de carte moment
c'est vraiment bizarre qu'il est pas
doué il aurait pu la coupe ehf m on
regardera ça mais je pense que l esra
palissy nous dans tous les cas c'est une
pochette vrai ça
il ya un truc violée
alors ça hein ah c'est un logo peut-être
d'une mutuelle ou des
entreprises mutuelles donc qu'ils
auraient volé sa une médecin purement ou
alors une infirmière libérale ou pesos
mais c'est vrai que c'est avec mon
médecin c'est sûrement médecin ok bon
bain plutôt intéressant sympa comme troy
bah ouais on va sûrement réussir à
retrouver la personne aille il reste une
pièce à
206 ou 1,1 centime ne sera pas
il ya toujours des pierres il reste
toujours un peu il en reste toujours la
vidéo de pêche allemand touche à sa fin
donc très belle dépollution ici surtout
mais aussi de superbes trouvaille voilà
c'est ça un bon nettoyage moi c'était
bien dégueulasse par contre on a trouvé
sur tous ces deux caisses avec la caisse
de médecins et la caisse qui suit avait
sûrement des pièces et des billets qui
malheureusement ne soit pas resté pour
moi important il peut être y est celle
là plus tôt mais il ya autre chose oui
façon en général quand il jette dans un
coin il aime bien revenir et jeté au
même endroit mais c'est en 2006 donc est
peut-être plus de paiement en liquide
chez le médecin aussi citer pas à
laisser un petit pouce bleus si vous
voulez que rasta et un autre parce qu'il
a été très sage arrière les ventes